hé les gars, je suis Alexa Medina et c'est la
réalité du hashtag salut aujourd'hui, nous allons
parler de mes quatre-vingt-dix millions de followers,
je ne peux pas croire que vous voyez que je m'appelle
Alexa mattina et que je suis une énorme [ __ ] oui
Alexa tu es dans mon  tourné
la vérité est que je ne suis qu'un nerd maladroit qui aime les chiens les
bonnes notes sont hilarantes je ne
pense pas que c'est ce dont ils se moquent l'
a trouvé errant dans les couloirs
reniflant ce marqueur magique c'est un
scandale et je nie toutes les accusations  tu as
deux amis Freddie et grand-mère grand-mère
est morte tu as besoin d'avoir des amis d'
accord hé je fais une fête samedi
tu devrais venir je pense que je pourrais probablement
oh ouais oh ouais je pense que je pourrais balancer
ça mm-
hmm c'est  une mauvaise idée tu n'as pas le
meilleur bilan avec ces gens je
t'ai dit que c'est une fête à la piscine
oh mon dieu je peux voir ce que la caméra aime
tu sais que tu fais du shopping avec nous
demain j'étais dans une seconde  Malibu
dans la prochaine j'étais trop flippante
fête des œufs mignons tu sais comme BFS maintenant je vais
ch  ange ma vie amusez-vous avec vos nouveaux
faux amis pourquoi ne pouvez-vous pas simplement être heureux
pour moi
hé les gars aujourd'hui nous allons parler de
Dani burns elle est une harceleuse vous pensiez que
j'allais juste la laisser voler mon
petit ami que vous avez perdu  toi-même
Freddie tu es mon meilleur ami
je suis désolé d'avoir été un imbécile pour toi un
imbécile bien plus gros je me suis perdu juste pour avoir des
likes d'un tas de gens que je
n'aime même pas
avez ici êtes
moins spécial vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
vous